Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is the restishistory.com. With TD Direct Investing, you can get live support. So whether you need help buying a partial share from your favorite tech company, opening a TFSA, or learning about investing tools, we're here to help. But keeping your cat off your keyboard? That's up to you. Reach out to TD Direct Investing today and make your investing steps count. Plus, enjoy 1% cash back. Conditions apply. Offer ends January 31, 2025.
感谢收听《历史的 rest》。想要获取每周独家播客、无广告收听、剧集抢先体验以及加入我们备受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。通过 TD 直投，您可以获得实时支持。因此，无论您是需要帮助购买您最喜欢的科技公司的碎股、开设 TFSA，还是了解投资工具，我们都在这里为您提供帮助。但管好您的猫，别让它踩在键盘上？那就得靠您自己了。立即联系 TD 直投，让您的每一步投资都算数。此外，还可享受 1% 现金返还。条款适用。优惠将于 2025 年 1 月 31 日结束。
Visit td.com slash di offer to learn more. Main Führer, your comrades at the first hour are seated before you, willing to follow your lead, nobly, as one united whole, to stride forth at your side in the future also, suffused by the single desire to follow you blindly, to avoid the attainment of the greatest of victories, the victory of our great German Volk. You have led us onward to victories unfathomable. You have restored to us a life worth living, a life splendid and magnificent. It was you who created Greater Germany. How feeble are our expressions of gratitude! Words to express our gratitude to you simply defy us.
访问 td.com 斜杠 di 优惠了解更多详情。伟大的元首，第一小时的同志们正坐在您面前，心甘情愿地追随您的领导，高贵地作为一个统一的整体，在未来也将与您并肩阔步前行，洋溢着盲目追随您的单一愿望，去实现最伟大的胜利，我们伟大的德意志人民的胜利。您引领我们走向了无法估量的胜利。您为我们恢复了值得过上的生活，一种辉煌壮丽的生活。正是您创造了大德意志。我们的感激之情是多么苍白无力！表达我们对您的感激之情的话语简直让我们词穷。
The cries with which we jubilantly hail you presently, mein Fuhrer, these shouts of hail, sum up everything we feel within ourselves in respect to inspiration, dedication, love and loyalty. Comrades, to our dearly beloved Fuhrer, the creator of Greater Germany, Sig Heil! Sig Heil! Sig Heil! So that Dominic was Herman Goering, who you've put down in your note, you've described as a sinister man mountain. I hope that I adequately conveyed your kind of instructions there. He's a gentleman of size, isn't he?
我们目前欢呼雀跃地迎接您的呐喊，我的元首，这些万岁声总结了我们在内心深处对激励、奉献、爱和忠诚的所有感受。同志们，为了我们深爱的元首，大德意志的缔造者，胜利万岁！胜利万岁！胜利万岁！所以多米尼克，那是赫尔曼·戈陵，你在笔记中写下的，你将他描述为一个面目可憎的庞然大物。我希望我很好地传达了你的那种指示。他是一个大块头的绅士，不是吗？
And I hope that that came across. This is going out early in January and that was actually his New Year address to the Reichstag on the 1st of January 1939. That was how Goering welcomed the New Year, Tom, and of course we always like to welcome the New Year with the company of these terrible people. New Year 1939 and Goering there, I think it's fair to say, is speaking for tens of millions of ordinary Germans. They all love their Fuhrer. Well, Hitler is very popular. And of course there are people who have issues with the regime of various kinds. There are things that are wrong with the regime, but a lot of ordinary Germans, I
我希望这传达出来了。这是在 1 月初播出的，那实际上是他 1939 年 1 月 1 日对国会的元旦演讲。戈陵就是这样迎接新年的，汤姆，当然我们总是喜欢在这些可怕的人的陪伴下迎接新年。1939 年的新年，我想可以公平地说，戈陵代表了数千万普通的德国人。他们都爱他们的元首。嗯，希特勒非常受欢迎。当然，也有人对这种或那种政权有意见。政权有不对劲的地方，但许多普通的德国人，我
think at the beginning of 1939 would say that Hitler's six years in power have brought a series of great achievements. They've rearmed the worst hardships of the depression over. They've re-armed the worst hardships of the Depression are over. They've re-occupied the Rhineland. They've unified with Austria. And now most recently, they have annexed the Sudetenland from Czechoslovakia. And they've done all of that without provoking the one thing that most of them fear, which is a European war. However, against that, it's not all good news, is it? Well, as we all know, and as is very well chronicled at the time in the newspapers of
认为在 1939 年初会说，希特勒执政的六年带来了一系列伟大的成就。他们重新武装了，大萧条最艰难的时期已经结束。他们重新武装了，大萧条最艰难的时期已经结束。他们重新占领了莱茵兰。他们与奥地利实现了统一。现在最近，他们从捷克斯洛伐克吞并了苏台德地区。他们做这一切都没有引发他们中最多数人害怕的一件事，那就是欧洲战争。然而，与之相对的，并非全是好消息，不是吗？嗯，正如我们所知，正如当时的报纸上非常详细记录的那样，
the world, there is the dark side to the Nazi regime, the concentration camps, the murders, the repression, the persecution above all of the Jews, symbolised by the Nuremberg Laws and the pogrom of Kristallnacht at the end of 1938. All of that is very well known. However, Hitler is genuinely popular at this point. It's a police state, of course, so it's hard to be certain. But all the evidence we have from journalists, from reports by the Social Democratic Party that were smuggled to their leadership in exile, are that people are delighted at Hitler's foreign policy achievements. Had he stopped, if the 1st of January 1939 he dropped dead or he'd stopped right then
纳粹政权有其黑暗的一面，集中营、谋杀、镇压，尤其是对犹太人的迫害，以纽伦堡法案和 1938 年底的水晶之夜大屠杀为象征。所有这一切都是众所周知的。然而，希特勒此时确实很受欢迎。当然这是一个警察国家，所以很难确凿。但我们从记者那里、从被走私给流亡领导层的社会民主党报告中得到的所有证据都表明，人们对希特勒的外交政策成就欣喜若狂。如果他停下来，如果他在 1939 年 1 月 1 日突然暴毙或者就在那时停下来
and said what we have we hold, we consolidate, I think Göring's verdict, ludicrously delivered as it was, would have resonated with millions of ordinary Germans. So can I ask you, the previous episode, we talked about how the German economy was on the brink. It was staring down the barrel of bankruptcy and this was a huge inspiration for conquering Czechoslovakia because it was a very rich country. Has the assimilation of the Czech economy enabled the German economy to be stabilised? And the short answer is no. Now, first of all, it's because of course they haven't assimilated the whole of the Czech economy. They've only? And the short answer is no. Now, first of all, it's because of course they haven't assimilated
并且说我们拥有的就是我们的，我们巩固下来，我想戈陵的判词——尽管发表得荒谬绝伦——会引起数百万普通德国人的共鸣。所以我想问你，上一集我们讨论了德国经济处于崩溃边缘。它正面临着破产的威胁，而这正是征服捷克斯洛伐克的巨大灵感来源，因为这是一个非常富裕的国家。捷克经济的同化是否使德国经济得以稳定？简短的回答是，没有。现在，首先是因为他们当然没有同化整个捷克经济。他们只？简短的回答是，没有。现在，首先是因为他们当然没有同化
the whole of the Czech economy. They've only taken the Sudetenland, which is what, about a fifth of Czechoslovakia's industrial capacity. But actually after they've done that, November 1938, Goering says to the rest of the Nazi high command, do you know what, we're actually in a terrible mess. So exactly as you say, Tom, Goering's four-year plan, as it was called, was predicated on constant conquest, on the constant acquisition of new resources, new labor, all of this. And actually, the wheels are about to come off and they're only keeping inflation at bay.
整个捷克经济。他们只拿下了苏台德地区，大约占捷克斯洛伐克工业能力的五分之一吧。但实际上在他们做到这一点之后，1938 年 11 月，戈陵对纳粹高级指挥部的其他人说，你知道吗，我们实际上陷入了巨大的混乱。所以正如你所说，汤姆，戈陵所谓的四年计划，是建立在不断征服、不断获取新资源、新劳动力之上的。事实上，车轮已经快要脱落了，他们只是在用价格管制来遏制通货膨胀。
So the inflation generated by their massive arm spending, they're only keeping it at bay with price controls. And as lots of people listening to this podcast will know, once you get into that world of price controls to stop inflation, you're often in a bit of a death spiral, a kind of economic death spiral. And actually, Goebbels writes in his diary in December 1938, the financial situation of the Reich is catastrophic. We must look for new ways. It cannot go on like this. And the obvious answer is, well, we just acquire new territory, we acquire new resources, just take stuff from ... if we haven't got enough workers, if we don't have enough currency, enough tungsten
因此，他们因大规模军费开支而产生的通货膨胀，只能通过价格管制来遏制。正如收听这个播客的许多人所知，一旦你进入那种通过价格管制来阻止通货膨胀的世界，你通常就会陷入某种死亡螺旋，一种经济死亡螺旋。实际上，戈培尔在 1938 年 12 月的日记中写道，帝国的财政状况是灾难性的。我们必须寻找新的出路。不能再这样下去了。显而易见的答案是，好吧，我们只是获取新领土，获取新资源，直接从……如果我们没有足够的工人，如果我们没有足够的货币、足够的钨
or whatever it might be. Or enough factories, we just nick the factories, everything. Take it from somebody else. And of course, the other thing that is propelling Hitler onwards, Hitler cannot stop. I mean, this is the thing, he is not an ordinary dictator. He is not even an ordinary German nationalist. H. A. P. Taylor, very famously and controversially in his book on the origins of the second world war published, I think in the 1960s said, well, Hitler was just a commoner garden German nationalist. His goals were those of German nationalists down the decades and
或其他什么东西。或者没有足够的工厂，我们就去偷工厂，什么都偷。从别人那里拿。当然，另一个推动希特勒不断前进的因素是，希特勒无法停下来。我的意思是，这就是问题所在，他不是一个普通的独裁者。他甚至不是一个普通的德国民族主义者。A. P. 泰勒（H. A. P. Taylor）在 20 世纪 60 年代左右出版的关于第二次世界大战起源的书中，非常著名且极具争议地说，好吧，希特勒只是一个平庸的德国民族主义者。他的目标是几十年来和
the centuries. That obviously is wrong, completely wrong. Hitler had said all this stuff in Mein Kampf and all his speeches in the 1920s, all of this stuff about nature, the law of struggle. We talked last time that quotation about people have to fight. Well, racist more specifically, isn't it? That there's a racial logic at play in Hitler's mind that if the Germans don't continue fighting, then stasis is not a possibility. They will lose. They will be defeated. They will be destroyed. So there's a thing that clearly separates him from another dictator of the same period, like a Franco or a Salazar or somebody like that in Spain and Portugal.
几个世纪以来德国民族主义者的目标。这显然是错误的，完全错误。希特勒在《我的奋斗》和他在 20 世纪 20 年代的每一次演讲中都说过所有这些关于自然、斗争规律的事情。我们上次谈到了关于人们必须战斗的那段引言。嗯，更具体地说具有种族色彩，不是吗？在希特勒的脑海中存在着一种种族逻辑，如果德国人不继续战斗，那么停滞是不可能的。他们会输。他们会被击败。他们会被消灭。所以有一点明显将他与同一时期的另一个独裁者区分开来，比如西班牙和葡萄牙的佛朗哥、萨拉查或类似的人。
But I guess not necessarily Stalin though, interestingly, because Stalin also as a communist dreams of the whole world going communist. Yes, he does. There's like a revolutionary dynamo inside Stalin, but Stalin is clearly much more pragmatic than Hitler is. Stalin doesn't have Hitler's Wagnerian urgency, I suppose, which we know that Hitler has. And this, of course, is one reason that Hitler is so disappointed when Munich doesn't give him a war and he's particularly disappointed, we entered last time, he's so disappointed with the German people. They've let themselves down because they were against war and they cheered Chamberlain
但我想斯大林不一定如此，有趣的是，因为斯大林作为一个共产主义者，也梦想着全世界都变成共产主义。是的，他是。斯大林内部有一种革命的发电机，但斯大林显然比希特勒务实得多。斯大林没有希特勒那种瓦格纳式的紧迫感，我想，我们知道希特勒有这种感觉。当然，这也是希特勒对慕尼黑没有给他带来战争感到如此失望的原因之一，他特别失望，我们上次结束时提到，他对德国人民感到如此失望。他们让自己失望了，因为他们反对战争并为张伯伦欢呼
because they thought he was a peacemaker. And for Hitler that suggests that they're on the road to degeneracy. Yes. So the longer you leave it, of course, the more degenerate they might well become. And of course, the longer you leave it, the more likely it is that Britain and France will rearm and it'll make also the Germany's economy will fall to pieces. So he really feels like that window is kind of closing all the time and he must move now. I mean, just to ask you on this thing about the economy, do British and French observers, I mean, do they have analysts who are pointing this out
因为他们认为他是和平缔造者。对希特勒来说，这表明他们正在走向堕落。是的。所以，当然，你拖得越久，他们就越有可能变得堕落。当然，你拖得越久，英国和法国重新武装的可能性就越大，这也将使德国经济分崩离析。所以他真的觉得这个窗口一直在关闭，他现在必须采取行动。我的意思是，顺便问一下关于经济的这件事，英国和法国的观察家们，我的意思是，他们是否有分析师指出这一点
that if we just leave it another year, the whole regime will implode economically? Because I've never actually read that in any account of the preparations for war. Whereas that today, you know, in a similar situation, people talk about it in terms of, you know, Russia against Ukraine or Iran or whatever, the sense that economic warfare can be as effective as tanks and planes. No, I don't think they do have that sense, Tom. I've never read anything that suggests that they do. Foreign visitors, when they go to Hitler's Germany, are struck by what they think of as his economic miracle, I would say. They're like, oh gosh, he's found the
如果我们再拖一年，整个政权将在经济上崩溃？因为我从来没有在任何关于战争准备的叙述中读到过这一点。而在今天，你知道，在类似的情况下，人们在谈论俄罗斯对乌克兰、伊朗或其他什么时，会提到经济战可以和坦克飞机一样有效的感觉。不，我不认为他们有这种感觉，汤姆。我从未读到过任何表明他们有这种感觉的东西。外国游客当他们去希特勒的德国时，会被他们认为是他的经济奇迹的东西所震撼，我想说。他们会想，哦天哪，他找到了
magic trick. He's put all these people back to work and Germany is humming again and everybody is happy and the streets are clear and all of that kind of thing. Springtime for Hitler. Springtime for Hitler, exactly. I think there's much more of a sense of that actually and a sense of great self-doubt in the democracies that maybe democracy doesn't really work. Maybe dictatorship is the future. So no, I don't think there's anything like that sort of sense. So at the beginning of 1939 I think it's fair to say that Hitler is determined to get his war sooner or later, the accent firmly on sooner, and the most
魔术。他让所有这些人都回去工作了，德国又在嗡嗡作响，每个人都很高兴，街道很干净，诸如此类的事情。希特勒的春天。希特勒的春天，正是如此。我认为实际上有更多那种感觉，而且民主国家内部有一种强烈的自我怀疑感，也许民主真的不管用。也许独裁才是未来。所以不，我不认为有什么类似的那种感觉。因此，在 1939 年初，我认为可以公平地说，希特勒决心迟早要打仗，重点坚决放在“早”，而最
obvious unfinished business is in what he would call, what everyone calls at the time, Czechoslovakia. It has been renamed after Munich, so to emphasize the fact that it has become a bit unglued and the Czech and Slovak parts have become unglued. So if you remember from last week, Hitler didn't just want the Sudetenland, he wanted the lot and he feels cheated. That fellow Chamberlain has spoiled my entry into Prague, he said. Is it not passing brave to be a dictator and ride in triumph through Prague? Exactly. That's part of his kind of Wagnerian fantasy in a life, isn't it? He sees himself riding up to the castle as a conqueror. So just three weeks after Munich,
明显的未竟事业是他所谓的、当时每个人都称为捷克斯洛伐克的地方。它在慕尼黑会议后被重新命名，以强调它已经有些解体，捷克和斯洛伐克部分已经解体的事实。因此，如果你还记得上周的话，希特勒不仅仅想要苏台德地区，他想要全部，他觉得自己被骗了。那个家伙张伯伦破坏了我进入布拉格的计划，他说。成为一个独裁者并在布拉格凯旋骑行，难道不是一件非常勇敢的事吗？正是如此。这是他生活中瓦格纳式幻想的一部分，不是吗？他把自己视为一个征服者骑马来到城堡。因此，就在慕尼黑会议三周后，
Hitler says to the Wehrmacht, to the German army, please draw up plans now for the liquidation of the remainder of the Czech state. Now the thing about this, of course, which reminds us how unusual Hitler is, is anybody else would say that this was completely unnecessary. Czechoslovakia is now no threat to you. You can really turn it into your puppet eventually. You don't need to risk everything by swallowing the rest of it. It's just supine at your feet. But he wants to have his conquest as a matter of pride. Secondly, I think, as we talked about last time, he really, really hates the Czechs. He's hated them ever since his days in Vienna before the first world war.
希特勒对国防军、德国军队说，请现在就制定计划，清算捷克国家的其余部分。当然，关于这一点，提醒我们希特勒是多么的不寻常，那就是任何其他人都会说这是完全没有必要的。捷克斯洛伐克现在对你构不成任何威胁。你最终真的可以把它变成你的傀儡。你不需要冒着吞并其余部分的风险去把一切都押上。它就在你的脚下顺从无比。但出于骄傲，他想要他的征服。其次，我想，正如我们上次讨论的那样，他真的、真的很讨厌捷克人。自从第一次世界大战前他在维也纳的日子起，他就一直讨厌他们。
And there is that economic thing that you talked about, Tom. So that they have the big Skoda works, they have all this foreign currency, they've got loads of gold and they've got this massive military arsenal. They have enough weapons in Czechoslovakia for 20 divisions. So that is about, if you think there's about 15,000 men in a division, I mean, that's a hell of a lot of guns. It is. And the Czechs have them. And their guns are better than anybody's. They've been made in this in Pilsen in this massive factory. And they're brilliant. And Hitler, for Hitler, there was no question in his mind, he's going to come back and get that a lot.
还有你谈到的那个经济问题，汤姆。所以他们有大型的斯柯达工厂，他们有所有这些外汇，他们有很多黄金，他们有这个庞大的军事军火库。捷克斯洛伐克的武器足够装备 20 个师。所以如果你认为一个师大约有 15,000 人，我的意思是，那是一大堆枪支。确实如此。而捷克人拥有这些。他们的枪比任何人的都好。它们是在比尔森的这个巨大工厂里制造的。它们非常出色。对希特勒来说，他的脑海里毫无疑问，他要回来把那些全部拿走。
So straight away in the new year, as soon as the Göring's splendid oration, the last echoes are dying away, Hitler starts to lay the groundwork with the army. He does three big speeches, the 18th of January, 25th of January, 10th of February, where he meets groups of officers, starting with the younger ones and then moving up to the senior commanders. And he says to them, he's completely explicit to this point. He says, I wanna make the German right, the dominant power in Europe.
所以新年伊始，一等戈陵那慷慨激昂的演讲余音袅袅，希特勒就开始与军队打下基础。他做了三次大型演讲，1 月 18 日、1 月 25 日、2 月 10 日，他会见了各组军官，从年轻的开始，然后逐步到高级指挥官。他对他们说，他对这一点完全明确。他说，我要让德国的权力成为欧洲的主导力量。
I want to ditch the democratic pacifist defeatist mentality that I associate with Weimar. At one point he says to these guys, the German heroes of the past embraced brutality, meaning the sword if other methods fail. It is time for Germany, and I quote, to stake its claim to the domination of Europe. So this isn't the talk of revising the Treaty
我想抛弃我与魏玛联系在一起的民主、和平主义、失败主义的心态。有一次他对这些家伙说，过去的德国英雄崇尚残酷，如果其他方法失败，就意味着剑。现在是时候让德国，我引述，“宣示其对欧洲统治权的权利”了。所以这不是修改凡尔赛条约的言论
of Versailles. No, it's not the kind of thing you could discuss with Neville Chamberlain. Yeah, a sympathetic journalist from the Daily Telegraph. You couldn't lay out these plans and hope to get a warm reception in the drawing rooms of Britain. And then the final one is that the Crawl Opera House is senior commanders and he says to them, look, I am determined to get this living space in the East. And he says, as long as I live, this thought will dominate my entire being. I will never draw back from the most extreme measures and I will need
不，这不是你可以和内维尔·张伯伦讨论的那种事情。是的，来自《每日电讯报》的富有同情心的记者。你不可能列出这些计划并希望在英国的客厅里受到热烈的欢迎。然后最后一次是在克罗尔歌剧院对高级指挥官们说的，看，我决心在东方获得这个生存空间。他说，只要我活着，这个想法将主导我的整个生命。我绝不会从最极端的措施中退缩，我需要
you to put your fervent trust in me. So there's no doubt about where all this is leading. This sort of slightly apocalyptic, you know, teenage boy planning and conquering the world, sort of Alexander the Great style vision, it's not hidden. No, well, this is the 100th anniversary of the publication of Mein Kampf. And it had been evident all these years. You only had to read it to know what his plans were. Yeah. I mean, this is the amazing thing, by the way, about Chamberlain's self-delusion. There's that phrase that people say, isn't there? They say it on social media when they're
你们对我寄予热切的信任。所以毫无疑问这一切将通向何方。这种略带末日色彩的、你知道的，像亚历山大大帝风格的十几岁男孩规划和征服世界的愿景，并没有被隐藏。不，好吧，这是《我的奋斗》出版 100 周年。这些年它一直显而易见。你只需要读一读就知道他的计划是什么。是的。我的意思是，顺便说一句，这就是张伯伦自我欺骗的惊人之处。有这样一句话，你知道吗？他们在社交媒体上试图对某人刻薄时会说
trying to be nasty to somebody. They say, when somebody shows you who they are, believe them. I mean, Hitler had showed people who he was for 20 years and people continued to underestimate him and to not believe him. But it's pretty open. Anyway, 13th of February, he tells his aides, right, we're going to do this. Let's start with Czechoslovakia and let us finish the job. Now, it's going to be easy. The Czechs, we talked about a lot last time, you were very agitated about this, Tom. Very agitated. I mean, they've got all these guns and they've got all their defenses and they've all been about terrible. But they've abandoned their fortified border positions in the Sudetenland and Czechoslovakia has federalized itself so he can basically use
当有人向你展示他们是谁时，相信他们。我的意思是，希特勒 20 年来一直在向人们展示他是谁，而人们继续低估他，不相信他。但这相当公开。无论如何，2 月 13 日，他告诉他的助手，好了，我们要这么做。让我们从捷克斯洛伐克开始，让我们完成这项工作。现在，这会很简单。捷克人，我们上次谈了很多，你对此非常激动，汤姆。非常激动。我的意思是，他们有所有这些枪支，他们有所有的防御工事，而且他们都非常糟糕。但他们已经放弃了他们在苏台德地区的防御边境阵地，而且捷克斯洛伐克已经实现了联邦化，所以他基本上可以利用
the Slovaks. He's going to use them as his pawn to kind of pull the whole thing apart. So the Slovak leader is a guy called Monsignor Josef Tiso, and Tiso is a kind of Catholic priest. He's ultra conservative, he's anti-Semitic. He's been the prime minister of the autonomous Slovak region since Munich. And he has terrible relations with the government in Prague, and they're always falling out. And on the 9th of March, they have a big row and the Prague government says, we've had enough of you mate.
斯洛伐克人。他要用他们作为他的棋子，把整个国家撕裂。所以斯洛伐克的领导人是一个叫约瑟夫·蒂索（Josef Tiso）的蒙席，蒂索是一个天主教神父。他是超保守的，他是反犹太主义的。自慕尼黑会议以来，他一直担任自治斯洛伐克地区的总理。他和布拉格政府的关系很糟糕，他们总是闹翻。3 月 9 日，他们发生了一场大争吵，布拉格政府说，老兄，我们受够你了。
And they send their police into Bratislava to dissolve Tiso's cabinet. And Hitler's like watching this and he says, oh, this is absolutely brilliant. This is the pretext we need. And he says to his inner circle, well, we'll strike on the Ides of March. Hitler loves a bit of a classical. It's like you Tom. That's deliberate. He deliberately phrases that.
他们派警察进入布拉格以解散蒂索的内阁。希特勒看着这一切说，哦，这绝对太棒了。这是我们需要借口。他对核心圈子说，好吧，我们将在三月伊德斯（凯撒遇刺日）那天发动袭击。希特勒喜欢一点古典。就像你一样，汤姆。那是故意的。他故意这样措辞。
Yes, exactly. He does. He references the Ides of March classical. So that's deliberate. He deliberately phrases that. Yes, exactly. He does. He references the Ides of March himself. Isn't that nice? So stabbing the Czechs in the back. Stabbing the Czechs in the back. On 13th of March, Tiso is flown to Berlin, this Slovak priest. Hitler says to him, right, I want you to declare independence and I want you to put Slovakia
是的，没错。他确实如此。他故意这样措辞。是的，没错。他确实如此。他自己引用了三月伊德斯的古典。所以那是故意的。他故意这样措辞。是的，没错。他确实如此。他自己引用了三月伊德斯。这不是很好吗？所以这是在背后捅捷克人一刀。在背后捅捷克人一刀。3 月 13 日，蒂索被空运到柏林，这个斯洛伐克神父。希特勒对他说，好吧，我要你宣布独立，我要你把斯洛伐克
under German protection. And Tiso actually says, really? German protection? And Hitler says, well, if you don't, I'll give Slovakia to Hungary. The Hungarians can't wait to get Slovakia back. So make up your mind. Tiso goes back to Bratislava and slightly sort of under duress, he proclaims Slovakian independence, but he doesn't follow through with the next part of it, which is calling for German protection. Hitler thinks this is very poor. So he sends German warships down the Danube. They train their guns on Bratislava.
置于德国的保护之下。蒂索实际上说，真的吗？德国保护？希特勒说，如果你不这样做，我就会把斯洛伐克给匈牙利。匈牙利人迫不及待地想把斯洛伐克拿回去。所以自己决定吧。蒂索回到布拉格，有点在胁迫下，宣布了斯洛伐克独立，但他没有落实下一部分，也就是呼吁德国保护。希特勒认为这太差劲了。于是他派德国军舰顺着多瑙河而下。他们把枪对准布拉格。
And that's it. And basically they say to Tiso, we'll fire on you unless you ask for our protection. Tiso asks for their protection. So the Czechs have been watching all this. Now the Czechs, Benes, he was left after Munich. So they have a new president and he's called Dr. Emil Haja. And he is not the ideal person to take on Heller. He's a lawyer, very experienced.
就是这样。他们基本上对蒂索说，除非你请求我们的保护，否则我们将向你开炮。蒂索请求了他们的保护。所以捷克人一直在看这一切。现在捷克人，贝尼斯，他在慕尼黑之后留下了。所以他们有了一个新总统，他叫埃米尔·哈哈（Emil Hacha）博士。他不是对付希特勒的理想人选。他是一名律师，非常有经验。
He's in his late sixties. He's a very clever and gentle and kind of cerebral man. Well, I'm amazed to read in your notes that he translated Jerome K. Jerome's Three Men and a Boat into Czech. He did. And a less Nazi text. Yeah. I find hard to think of.
他快六十多岁了。他是一个非常聪明、温和、富有理性的人。嗯，我很惊讶地在你的笔记中读到他把杰罗姆·K·杰罗姆的《三人同舟》翻译成了捷克语。他确实翻译了。而且是一个不太纳粹的文本。是的。我觉得很难想到。
That stuff with the dog and the cheese. Yeah. Brilliant. And the picnic hamper. Yeah. Amazing. And I heartily recommend Three Men and a Boat to our listeners, but I mean, it's not, you don't want an expert on Three Men and a Boat.
那些关于狗和奶酪的东西。是的。太棒了。还有野餐篮。是的。太惊人了。我热烈推荐我们的听众去读《三人同舟》，但我的意思是，这不是，你不需要一个《三人同舟》的专家。
Doesn't prepare you for confronting the Third Reich. No, it does not. Although you could say all of Britain had read three men and a boat and we defeated the Third Reich. That's true. So maybe it does. Who knows? Maybe if more Czechs had read three men and a boat, the story
这并不能让你为面对第三帝国做好准备。不，并没有。尽管你可以说整个英国都读过《三人同舟》，而我们击败了第三帝国。那是真的。所以也许它确实有帮助。谁知道呢？也许如果更多的捷克人读过《三人同舟》，故事
would have ended very differently. Right. We shouldn't laugh about this because it's a very tragic story. Hacher, his daughter and the foreign minister, travel by train to Berlin. He's asked for a meeting with Hitler. Takes them five hours and they arrive in the evening of the 14th of March. Hitler behaves,
的结局就会大不相同。好吧。我们不应该对此笑，因为这是一个非常悲惨的故事。哈哈、他的女儿和外交部长乘火车前往柏林。他请求与希特勒会面。花了他五个小时，他们在 3 月 14 日傍晚抵达。希特勒表现得，
he's a very poor host, I think it's fair to say. Hitler keeps this guy, Hacher, waiting. This is his standard approach, isn't it? When brow-beating foreign leaders, whose countries he's about to take over. Same with Austria. Yeah, exactly the same. He keeps him waiting in this hotel, always hotels with Hitler. What is it with Hitler in hotels? He keeps this bloke waiting in a hotel for ages while he is finishing watching a film, a comedy I think, called Ein Hoffnungsloser Fall, which means a hopeless case. An ominous title there for the Czechs. Finally at midnight Hitler says right I finished the film, get this bloke over to the Reich Chancellery. So Hacher is brought to the Reich Chancellery and there they make
我认为可以公平地说，他是一个非常糟糕的主人。希特勒让这个家伙哈哈一直等着。这是他的标准做法，不是吗？当霸凌他即将接管其国家的外国领导人时。对奥地利也是如此。是的，完全一样。他在一家酒店里让哈哈等了很久，希特勒总是待在酒店里。希特勒对酒店有什么执念？他在一家酒店里让这家伙等了很久，同时他还在看完一部电影，我想是一部喜剧，叫《无可救药的案例》（Ein Hoffnungsloser Fall）。对捷克人来说是一个不祥的标题。最后在午夜，希特勒说，好吧，我看完了电影，把这家伙带到帝国总理府。所以哈哈被带到了帝国总理府，在那里他们
him inspect the Guard of Honour. You have all their guns and stuff and their steel helmets and... A sort of humiliation for him. Do they have the skulls at this point? Yeah, there's probably a lot of skulls. To be fair, the Kaiser had all sorts of uniforms with skulls on, didn't he? So even great associates the rest of history have kind of got a bit of skull decoration. At 1am, Harker is shown into Hitler's massive study in the right chance for him. It's absolutely rammed at people. So all the bad guys are there. Ribbentrop's
让他检阅仪仗队。你们所有的枪支和装备以及他们的钢盔……对他的某种羞辱。他们这个时候有头骨标志吗？是的，可能有很多头骨。公平地说，德皇有各种带有头骨的制服，不是吗？所以连《历史的 rest》的伟大合作者也有点头骨装饰。凌晨 1 点，哈哈被领进帝国总理府希特勒那间巨大的书房里。里面简直挤满了人。所以所有的坏蛋都在那里。里宾特洛普
there. Goering is there. Wilhelm Keitel, the general, is there. And Harker, this guy is very, very nervous. Is he polishing his glasses as they steam up? He undoubtedly isn't thinking about Jerome K. Jerome. Thinking wistfully about comic songs. Exactly. Hitler launches into this massive rant against the Czechs. He says, I've had enough of you, you know, you're terrible people. And to protect our security, I'm going to impose a protectorate over Czechoslovakia. I'm going to absorb it into the Reich and it'll become a protectorate of Germany. My troops, he says, are on their way. Too late, they can't be recalled. They're going to cross your into the Reich and it'll become a protectorate of Germany. My troops, he says, are on their way.
在那里。戈陵在那里。将军威廉·凯特尔在那里。而哈哈，这家伙非常非常紧张。当他们的眼镜起雾时，他是在擦眼镜吗？毫无疑问，他一定没有在想杰罗姆·K·杰罗姆。满怀留恋地想着滑稽歌曲。正是如此。希特勒开始对捷克人大发雷霆。他说，我受够了你们，你知道，你们是很糟糕的人。为了保护我们的安全，我将在捷克斯洛伐克强加一个保护国。我要把它并入帝国，它将成为德国的保护国。我的军队，他说，正在路上。太迟了，无法召回。他们要越过你的进入帝国，它将成为德国的保护国。我的军队，他说，正在路上。
Too late. They can't be recalled. They're going to cross your border at six o'clock in the morning. I want you to ring Prague, tell your people to offer no resistance and if they offer any resistance we'll kill you and we'll crush them." And Göring, he chimes in for good measure. He says, oh, my air force, the Luftwwaffe will be over Prague by dawn and it's up to you whether they bomb your city into dust or not. Presumably though, Hitler doesn't want Prague bombed into the dust because he wants the castle.
太迟了。无法召回。他们将在清晨六点穿过你们的边境。我要你给布拉格打电话，告诉你们的人不要进行抵抗，如果他们进行抵抗，我们会杀了你，我们会粉碎他们。”戈陵也插话进来壮声势。他说，哦，我的空军，空军将在黎明前飞越布拉格，他们是将你们的城市炸成灰烬还是怎样，由你决定。不过据推测，希特勒并不想把布拉格炸成灰烬，因为他想要那座城堡。
No, I don't think he does. It's not exactly an empty threat, but it's pure blackmail. And at that, I mean, incredibly, although not incredibly, you might say, Harker collapses. He just collapses. He falls to the ground in a dead faint. Some sources say he may well have had a heart attack at that point and he drops to the ground. And the Nazis, they're actually quite thrown by this because they're terrified that everybody will say they've murdered him, which is very bad PR for them to murder the president. Yeah, it's a very bad look.
不，我想他并不想。这不完全是一个空洞的威胁，但这是纯粹的勒索。听到这个，我的意思是，令人难以置信的是，尽管并非不可信，你可能会说，哈哈崩溃了。他直接崩溃了。他昏倒在地，死一般地昏过去。一些消息来源说他当时很可能心脏病发作了，他倒在了地上。而纳粹分子，他们实际上对这感到相当惊慌，因为他们害怕每个人都会说他们谋杀了总统，这对他们的公关来说是非常糟糕的。是的，这看起来非常糟糕。
Of course, Hitler's doctor, Dr. Morel, who's the guy who was always giving him cocktails of amphetamine. Amphetamine. So he gives them some speed. Yeah. He's on hand with an injection. They managed to bring Hacher back to life, get him back up. He says, oh, fine, I'll ring Prague.
当然，希特勒的医生莫雷尔医生，就是那个总是给他注射安非他命鸡尾酒的人。安非他命。所以他给他们注射了安非他命。是的。他手头有一针。他们设法让哈哈苏醒过来，让他重新站起来。他说，哦，好吧，我给布拉格打电话。
He goes to ring Prague. It's very like the Munich conference. Telephones don't work. The phones aren't working. And the Luftwaffe I'll ring Prague. He goes to ring Prague. It's very like the Munich conference. Telephones don't work. The phones aren't working. And the Lufthansa are heading towards Prague. At this point, Ribbentrop has a massive strop at this point, a massive meltdown. He says, oh my God, the phones never work here. It's like Britain in the 1970s.
他去给布拉格打电话。这非常像慕尼黑会议。电话打不通。电话坏了。而空军我给布拉格打电话。他去给布拉格打电话。这非常像慕尼黑会议。电话打不通。电话坏了。而德国汉莎航空正朝布拉格驶去。此时，里宾特洛普大发雷霆，彻底崩溃了。他说，哦，天哪，这里的电话从来都没用过。这就像 20 世纪 70 年代的英国。
The phones aren't working. Nothing works here. Everything is rubbish. You know, he's kind of ranting raving. Actually, he's being a bit harsh on his own phone system. It turns out the problem is actually with the exchange in Prague, not with Berlin. So Ribbentrop is being too harsh towards German telephone engineering. He's talking Germany down.
电话坏了。这里什么都不管用。一切都是垃圾。你知道，他在咆哮疯狂。实际上，他对自己的电话系统有点太苛刻了。事实证明，问题实际上出在布拉格的交换机上，而不是柏林。所以里宾特洛普对德国的电话工程太苛刻了。他在唱衰德国。
Why does Ribbentrop hate Germany? Sad. Shocking. Anyway, finally Harker does get through to Prague and he says, okay, don't fight, don't fight, don't resist. And at four o'clock in the morning, under tremendous pressure, I mean, it is a really, really tragic scene. He signs a declaration that he is putting his people under the protection of the German Reich.
为什么里宾特洛普讨厌德国？真可悲。太令人震惊了。无论如何，哈哈终于打通了布拉格的电话，他说，好吧，不要打仗，不要打仗，不要抵抗。在凌晨四点，在巨大的压力下，我的意思是，这真的是一个非常非常悲惨的场景，他签署了一项声明，宣布他将自己的人民置于德意志帝国的保护之下。
So Harker kind of collapses again. Hitler is absolutely overjoyed. And this is the first proper annexation that has no kind of pretence that we're irredentism. No. These are German, you know, we're taking them back. This is out and out kind of colonial conquest. Pure colonial conquest. And Hitler is probably as excited and happy about this as he's been about anything because
所以哈哈再次崩溃了。希特勒欣喜若狂。这是第一次没有任何强词夺理、假装是收复失地的正式吞并。没有。这些是德国人，你知道，我们正在把他们带回。这是赤裸裸的殖民征服。纯粹的殖民征服。希特勒可能为此感到前所未有的兴奋和高兴，因为
he goes in to see his secretaries. They're called Krister Schröder and Gerda Derinovsky. And he famously says to them, one of them, I can't remember which one it is, tells the story. He goes in, he says, so children, to the secretaries and he points to his cheeks of his face. He says, I want each one of you to give me a kiss here and here. This is the happiest day of my life. What has been striven for in vain for centuries, I have been fortunate enough to bring about. I will go down as the greatest German in history. He's no longer crippled by self-doubt at this point. No, I think it's fair to say he's not crippled by self-doubt.
他进去见他的秘书。她们叫克里斯特·施罗德（Christa Schroeder）和格达·克里斯蒂安（Gerda Christian，原姓Daranovsky）。他著名地对她们说，其中一个，我不记得是哪一个了，讲了这个故事。他走进去说，孩子们，对秘书们指着他脸颊说，我要你们每个人在这里和这里给我一个吻。这是我一生中最快乐的日子。几年来一直徒劳追求的事情，我有幸实现了。我将作为历史上最伟大的德国人载入史册。此时他不再受到自我怀疑的折磨。不，我认为可以公平地说，他没有受到自我怀疑的折磨。
So two hours later, right on time, the first German units cross the border into their new protectorate. Again, this is the first time that they have not been greeted by cheering crowds. So that again is a reminder how different this is from the Rhineland or from Austria or even the Sudetenland. There's nobody cheering, there's nobody with flowers, there's nobody saluting. By and large, the Czech people stay indoors, they're horrified. It's a misty, snowy day. It's a funereal atmosphere. Hitler crosses the border later that day by train, then he transfers to this kind of fleet of Mercedes cars. And now he can go to Prague, which is kind of what he'd wanted all along, right?
两个小时后，准时，第一批德国部队越过边界进入他们的新保护国。同样，这是他们第一次没有受到欢呼人群的欢迎。这再次提醒人们，这与莱茵兰、奥地利甚至苏台德地区有多么不同。没有人欢呼，没有人拿着鲜花，没有人行礼。大体上，捷克人民都待在室内，他们感到惊恐。这是一个有雾、下雪的日子。这是一个充满葬礼气氛的日子。希特勒当天晚些时候乘火车过境，然后换乘了一支梅赛德斯汽车车队。现在他可以去布拉格了，这正是他一直想要的，对吧？
I mean, his ultimate object. He's got his arm outstretched in the salute as he passes all his troops who are columns of troops heading into Czechoslovakia. He reaches Prague, night has fallen. He goes right up to the castle. If anyone's been to Prague. Amazing. Dominates the city. Dominates the city. The kings of Bohemia, Holy Roman Emperors, Rudolf II had been there. He goes up. The castle is dark and abandoned. To his great displeasure, it's like when Ted Heath became Prime Minister and arrived at number 10 Downing Street, there's no food. This was the case, Tom, in 1970. There's no food at the Prague Castle in 1939 and Hitler sends his military escort out to
我的意思是，他的最终目标。当他经过开进捷克斯洛伐克的成列军队时，他伸长手臂行着军礼。他到达布拉格时，夜幕已经降临。他径直走到城堡。如果有人去过布拉格。太棒了。俯瞰这座城市。俯瞰这座城市。波希米亚国王、神圣罗马帝国皇帝、鲁道夫二世曾在那儿。他上去了。城堡黑漆漆的，荒废着。令他非常不快的是，就像希斯成为首相并抵达唐宁街 10 号时一样，没有食物。汤姆，1970 年就是这种情况。1939 年布拉格城堡里没有食物，希特勒派他的军事护卫队出去
find food. They bring back ham and bread and some Czech beer lager. Hitler doesn't like the beer, which is madness because Czech beer is very good. He says it's too bitter. Not pleased at all. So to add to Hitler's many faults is an inability to appreciate Czech beer. Yes, exactly. Exactly.
找食物。他们带回了火腿、面包和一些捷克啤酒拉格。希特勒不喜欢这种啤酒，这太疯狂了，因为捷克啤酒非常好。他说它太苦了。一点也不高兴。所以，在希特勒的众多缺点中又添了一条：无法欣赏捷克啤酒。是的，正是如此。正是如此。
Add that to the charge sheet. He issues this proclamation which he says, the Bohemian and Moravian lands had belonged to the living space of the German people for a thousand years, which is not really true. And he says now they've been reunited with their masters. Those are kind of the Habsburg words, aren't they? Those are the words that the Habsburg Empire had used. Bohemian Moravia. Yes, exactly.
把这加到罪状清单上。他发表了这篇公告，其中说，波希米亚和摩拉维亚的土地千年来一直属于德意志人民的生存空间，这并不是真的。他说现在他们已经与他们的主人团聚了。这些有点像哈布斯堡王朝的话，不是吗？那是哈布斯堡帝国曾使用过的词汇。波希米亚摩拉维亚。是的，正是如此。
And they nick the crown crown jewels don't they take them back to Germany. Yes they do. The Bohemia Moravia becomes part of the Reich, the Slovak state becomes under Monsignor Tiso becomes a kind of clerical fascist puppet state of Germany and the last bit of Czechoslovakia which is over in the east, Subcarpathian Ruthenia is taken initially by Hungary and then it actually ends up being part of Ukraine in the Soviet Union later on and remains Ukrainian to this day. So the Czechs never get it back. And a first in the protectorate of Bohemia and Moravia there is a sort of pretence of autonomy so that there's
他们偷走了王冠珠宝，把它们带回了德国。是的，他们确实这么做了。波希米亚-摩拉维亚成为帝国的一部分，在蒂索蒙席统治下的斯洛伐克国成为德国的一个天主教法西斯傀儡国，而捷克斯洛伐克的最后一部分，在东部的喀尔巴阡山以南的鲁塞尼亚，最初被匈牙利占领，后来实际上在苏联时期成为了乌克兰的一部分，直到今天仍然是乌克兰的领土。所以捷克人再也没有把它拿回来。在波希米亚和摩拉维亚保护国内，最初有一种自治的假象，即
still a Czech president, still a prime minister and so on, the Czech courts but over time of course all this begins to disappear. Jews are repressed, the state's assets are plundered, and it really becomes worse when Heydrich from the SS becomes the deputy protector in 1941. And then he gets shot, doesn't he, in their terrible reprisals. Exactly. So Hitler returns to Berlin in triumph, sort of Roman style, like a conqueror, great crowds. Göring is there with kind of great tears on his fat face. And now everyone's happy. Everyone in Germany kind of happy, are they?
仍然有捷克总统、总理等等，有捷克法庭，但随着时间的推移，所有这一切当然都开始消失了。犹太人受到镇压，国家的资产被掠夺，当来自党卫军的海德里希在 1941 年成为副保护国长官时，情况变得更加糟糕。然后他被枪杀了，不是吗，在他们可怕的报复中。正是如此。因此，希特勒凯旋回到柏林，有点罗马风格，像个征服者，欢呼的人群。戈陵也在那里，他肥胖的脸上流着大颗的眼泪。现在每个人都很高兴。德国的每个人都挺高兴的，是吗？
Well, this is the interesting thing, right? So the Nazi high commander happy, Nazi true believers are very happy. They've got a conquest. But for ordinary Germans, I don't know that they care very much about Bohemia and Moravia. I mean, nobody thinks that these are an integral part of the right. Like they've never been part of Germany. In his biography of Hitler, Ian Kershaw quotes a teenage girl from Paderborn. Oh, where the Pope went to meet Shalemane.
嗯，这就是有趣的地方，对吧？所以纳粹高级指挥官很高兴，纳粹忠实信徒非常高兴。他们得到了一个征服。但对于普通德国人来说，我不知道他们是否很在意波希米亚和摩拉维亚。我的意思是，没有人认为这些是帝国的不可分割的一部分。就像它们从未成为德国的一部分一样。在其希特勒传记中，伊恩·克肖（Ian Kershaw）引用了来自帕德博恩的一个十几岁女孩的话。哦，教皇去见查理曼大帝的地方。
Right, exactly. I think this is from a girl's diary. The girl's mother said, is he never satisfied? Can't he get enough? And the girl herself writes in her diary, she says, I completely understand why we took the Sedatian Lancers full of Germans, but why are we taking over an entirely alien people, that's those are her words, who cannot possibly be turned into Germans? Because of course the 1930s, it is an age of nationalist thinking.
没错，正是如此。我想这是出自一个女孩的日记。女孩的母亲说，他难道永远不知足吗？他难道拿不够吗？女孩自己在日记中写道，她说，我完全理解为什么我们拿下了充满德国人的苏台德，但为什么我们要接管一个完全异质的人民——那是她的话——根本不可能把他们变成德国人呢？因为当然在 20 世纪 30 年代，这是一个民族主义思想的时代。
When ethnic nationalism is so important to people, it constructs the way they view the world. So for Germans who've been brought up on ethnic nationalism and linguistic nationalism to suddenly have all these checks in the Reich doesn't make any sense. What are they doing there? And I suppose also more Jews and of course, more Jews, exactly. Which will be even more the case when we turn to Poland later on.
当族裔民族主义对人们如此重要时，它构建了他们看待世界的方式。因此，对于在族裔民族主义和语言民族主义教育下长大的德国人来说，突然让所有这些捷克人进入帝国是没有任何意义的。他们在那里做什么？我想还有更多的犹太人，当然，更多的犹太人，正是如此。当我们稍后转向波兰时，情况将更加如此。
And even Nazi Party reports themselves, slightly sort of reluctantly said, most people are actually pretty, they don't quite understand this. They're grudging, they're even critical, they don't understand why it was necessary. Richard Evans in his book on the Third Reich, he quotes a worker who said, we were always winning these days, but we were always winning once before and that came to a bad end. So in other words, there is a slight sense of foreboding about all this. I think this is Hitler's first really, really serious misstep because I think much more than Munich, this is the moment that destroys the case for appeasement. Because if you were massively pro appeasement, even after Munich, you could say, well, we've avoided war and really the Sedecin is full of Germans. You could say that.
甚至连纳粹党自己的报告也有些不情愿地表示，大多数人实际上相当，他们不太明白这一点。他们是勉强的，甚至是批评的，他们不明白为什么这是必要的。理查德·埃文斯在他关于第三帝国的书中引用了一个工人的话，他说，这些天我们总是在获胜，但我们以前也总是在获胜，而那却以糟糕的结局收场。换句话说，对于这一切有一种隐约的不祥预感。我认为这是希特勒第一次真正非常严重的失误，因为我认为比起慕尼黑，这是摧毁绥靖政策理由的时刻。因为如果你极力赞成绥靖，即使在慕尼黑之后，你也可以说，好吧，我们避免了战争，而且苏台德真的到处都是德国人。你可以这么说。
And he had signed his piece of paper, hadn't he? You were saying in the previous episode how actually that is very important. People laugh at it, but it now enables Chamberlain, I guess, to feel, I've done my best and now I have no chance and everyone in Britain to agree with that. I mean, I think this is what you might say would be the revisionist case for appeasement, which is if you give Hitler every possible chance, then when the crunch comes, you will have a united country where everybody says, look, clearly we gave him every opportunity. Apart from unity, of course.
而且他签了那张纸，不是吗？你在上一集里提到，其实这非常重要。人们对此付诸一笑，但我想，这现在让张伯伦能够觉得，我已经尽力了，现在我没有别的机会了，而且英国的每个人都会赞同这一点。我的意思是，我认为这就是你所说的对绥靖政策的修正主义观点，也就是说，如果你给希特勒所有可能的退路，那么当危机真正降临时，你就会拥有一个团结的国家，每个人都会说，看，显然我们已经给了他所有的机会。当然，除了团结。
Apart from unity, Mifflin Oswald Mosley, we gave him every opportunity and he showed himself to be a total and utter shyster. And the same reaction in France is this? Absolutely the same reaction in France. So in France, de Ladié, the prime minister who had been there in Munich, of course, looking like a snail, looking very miserable. He says to his chamber of deputies, right, okay, fine. It's very clear now we have to prepare for war.
除了团结，米夫林·奥斯瓦尔德·莫斯利，我们给了他所有的机会，而他证明了自己是一个彻头彻尾的骗子。法国的反应也是如此吗？法国的反应完全一样。所以在法国，达拉第，那位曾在慕尼黑出席的首相，当然，他看起来像只蜗众、显得非常痛苦。他对他的众议院说，好吧，行。很明显，现在我们必须为战争做准备了。
And they vote him emergency powers in the nation's defence after this moment. In Britain, every newspaper, The Observer, which had been a pro-appeasement newspaper, had said this was, and I quote, the most shameful and ominous page in the modern annals of Europe. The brilliant diarist, the Tory MP, Chips Chanon. He'd been an ultra appeaser, a massive admirer of Chamberlain. No bolder bolder departure from the written bond has ever been committed in history. The manner of its surpassed comprehension and Hitler's callous desertion of the prime minister is stupefying. I can never forgive him. So in other words, this business, I think, is not as famous actually as Munich or the attack on Boland, I think really, really matters.
在这一刻之后，他们投票授予他在国家防御方面的紧急权力。在英国，每一家报纸——《观察家报》，曾经是一份亲绥靖政策的报纸——都曾说这是——我引述一下——“现代欧洲年鉴中最耻辱、最不祥的一页”。才华横溢的日记作家、托利党议员奇普斯·查农。他曾是一个极端的绥靖主义者、张伯伦的崇拜者。“历史上从未发生过比这更公然背弃书面承诺的事情。其方式超出了理解能力，希特勒对首相冷酷无情的抛弃令人瞠目结舌。我永远无法原谅他。”换句话说，这件事，我认为，实际上并不像慕尼黑事件或对波兰的进攻那样出名，但我认为它真的、真的很重要。
And Chamberlain at first doesn't quite get it. He gives a speech in the House of Commons that's very perfunctory and doesn't quite match the mood of the moment. But then two days later, which is the 17th of March, he goes to give a speech in Birmingham, of course, the Chamberlain stronghold, and he clearly by this point has changed his tune because he strikes his hardest line yet. He says, it's very clear now, Hitler intends, and I quote, to dominate the world by force. If that's right, we will stop him.
张伯伦一开始并没有完全领会这一点。他在下议院发表了一篇非常敷衍的演讲，完全不符合当时的气氛。但两天后，也就是3月17日，他去伯明翰发表演讲，那当然是张伯伦的大本营，到了这个时候他显然已经改变了调门，因为他摆出了迄今为止最强硬的姿态。他说，现在非常明显，希特勒的企图是——我引述一下——“用武力统治世界”。如果真是这样，我们将阻止他。
He says Britain will take part to the utmost of its power in resisting such a challenge. If it were made. And I think here, actually as in 1938, he speaks for the nation. He's reflecting the public mood. You can see it in papers and letters and diaries in Britain and in France. With this attack on Czechoslovakia, Hitler really has crossed the line and there is no going back now. We know what kind of man he is.
他说，英国将尽其最大力量参与抵抗这种挑战。如果它发生的话。我认为在这里，实际上就像在1938年一样，他代表了国家。他在反映公众的情绪。你可以在英国和法国的报纸、信件和日记中看到这一点。通过对捷克斯洛伐克的这次进攻，希特勒真的越过了底线，现在已经没有回头路了。我们知道他是个什么样的人。
And so now Chamberlain is looking for, you know, he's abandoned Czechoslovakia. Yeah. But is there another country where he can kind of draw a red line along its border? Exactly. He's saying, where are we going to draw the line? And the very next day, 18th of March, he meets his cabinet and he says exactly that. Like, okay, we draw the line now. One more step and it is war. Where will Hitler's next challenge come?
所以现在张伯伦在寻找，你知道的，他抛弃了捷克斯洛伐克。是的。但是有没有另一个国家，他可以在其边界划一条红线呢？没错。他说，我们要把线划在哪里？紧接着的第二天，即3月18日，他会见内阁，并且明确表达了这一点。就像，好吧，我们现在划定红线。再往前一步就是战争。希特勒的下一个挑战会从哪里来？
And Chamberlain is in no doubt the key to the future of Europe, he says, will be Poland. Right. So let's take a break now. And when we're back, we will come at last to the country where as everyone listening to this will know, the Second World War begins. Hello, welcome back to The Rest is History. It's been a long sweep, hasn't it? This history of the rise of the Nazis, they're going to power, the road to the Second World War, and now at last the Second World War is hoving into view because we have come to the country for which Britain and France went to war to defend it and that of course is Poland. Yes.
张伯伦毫不怀疑，欧洲未来的关键，他说，将会是波兰。好吧，我们现在休息一下。当我们回来时，我们将终于来到这个国家——正如所有收听这档节目的人所知，第二次世界大战就是在这里爆发的。你好，欢迎回到《历史的余烬》。这是一段漫长的历程，不是吗？这段关于纳粹崛起、他们夺取政权、通往第二次世界大战的道路，现在终于，第二次世界大战已经隐约可见，因为我们来到了那个英国和法国为之参战去保卫的国家，那当然就是波兰。是的。
So Poland, Polish history 101. Poland had vanished from the map of Europe after 1795 for more than 120 years. It had been partitioned between the empires, as lots of people will know, between the empires of Russia, Prussia and Austria. And Poland got its independence back at the end of the first world war. And it's one of the largest countries in Central Europe. It's 31 million people. But Poland, unlike Czechoslovakia, is very, very rickety. So because it's been carved out of three different empires, nothing is joined up. It doesn't even have a joined up railway network.
所以，波兰，波兰历史101。1795年以后，波兰从欧洲地图上消失了120多年。正如很多人所知，它被各大帝国瓜分了，在俄罗斯、普鲁士和奥地利的帝国之间。波兰在第一次世界大战结束时恢复了独立。它是中欧最大的国家之一。它拥有3100万人口。但是波兰，与捷克斯洛伐克不同，非常、非常摇晃。因为它是从三个不同的帝国拼凑出来的，所以什么都没有整合在一起。它甚至没有一个整合的铁路网。
Because they've all got different gauges. Yeah, exactly. It's very rural, by and large. A lot of it is very poor. A lot of the First World War in the East was fought in Poland, so it's scarred by war. Like a lot of Central European countries, it has an issue with minorities. Basically, it's meant to be an ethnic nation state, but you can't draw the boundaries perfectly. So they don't feel that diversity is their strength. They do not feel that diversity is their strength. Only about two thirds of the population are ethnic Poles. So if you look at the census, there's about four million Ukrainians, there
因为它们的轨道标准都不一样。是的，没错。总的来说，它非常乡村化。很大一部分地区非常贫困。第一次世界大战在东方的许多战斗都是在波兰打响的，所以它饱受战争的满目疮痍。就像许多中欧国家一样，它有少数族裔的问题。基本上，它应该是一个民族国家，但你无法把边界画得完美。所以他们不认为多样性是他们的力量。他们不认为多样性是他们的力量。人口中只有大约三分之二的民族波兰人。所以如果你看一下人口普查，大约有四百万乌克兰人，这里
are three million people who are identified in the census as Jews, there are a million Belarusians, there are almost a million Silesian Germans. And that, I guess, is the key thing for Hitler. Of course. In fact, again, unlike Czechoslovakia or far more than Czechoslovakia, none of Poland's neighbors like it. Everybody thinks it's illegitimate. Everybody contests its borders. And it's an extraordinary thing that in the three years after 1918, the Poles fought six
有三百万人在人口普查中被识别为犹太人，有一百万白俄罗斯人，有将近一百万西里西亚德国人。我想，对希特勒来说，这才是关键所在。当然。事实上，同样与捷克斯洛伐克不同，或者说比捷克斯洛伐克更甚，波兰没有一个邻国喜欢它。所有人都认为它是非法的。所有人都在对它的边界提出异议。这是一件非同寻常的事情，在1918年之后的三年里，波兰人打了六场
separate frontier wars. Well, I guess, I mean, if it's been reconstituted out of the territory of great empires, great powers, then I mean that's inevitable isn't it? Of course it is. They pretty much fight every single one of their neighbours, most famously the Soviet Union, they turn them back in the miracle on the Vistula when they defeat the Bolsheviks. You know, it's a terrible thing for the Poles, they're trapped between two much larger, much richer neighbours, both of whom regard Poland as illegitimate, and
独立的前沿战争。嗯，我想，我的意思是，如果它是从各大帝国、大国的领土上重建起来的，那么这意味着这是不可避免的，对吧？当然是的。他们几乎与每一个邻国都发生了战斗，其中最著名的是苏联，他们在维斯瓦河的奇迹中击退了苏联人，当时他们击败了布尔什维克。你知道，这对波兰人来说是一件可怕的事情，他们被夹在两个大得多、富有得多的邻国之间，这两个邻国都视波兰为非法，并且
they are Germany and the Soviet Union. And you would have to say that being trapped between Stalin and Hitler is not to have been served first prize in the lottery of life geopolitically, is it? No, it's not. To pick up an analogy that we mentioned in the last week's series about Munich, it's rather like you're on that plane strapped between gering and ribbon-trop. And actually things don't get any better for the Poles. They suffer massive inflation and unemployment in the 1920s and 30s. A million people emigrate, mostly to the United States. They can't sustain their
它们是德国和苏联。你不得不说，夹在斯大林和希特勒之间，在政治地缘上并没有在生命的大抽奖中抽到头等奖，不是吗？不，确实没有。借用我们在上周关于慕尼黑的系列节目中提到过的一个比喻，这有点像你坐在那架飞机上，被夹在戈林和里宾特洛甫之间。事实上，波兰人的境况并没有变得更好。他们在20世纪20年代和30年代遭受了大规模的通货膨胀和失业。有一百万人移民，大部分去了美国。他们无法维持他们的
democracy. So there's a coup in 1926 by the great wartime nationalist hero Marshall Pilsudski. And then they have an authoritarian regime called the Sanatia regime, which means the kind of healing regime. And this is a kind of nationalist authoritarian regime. The key person in this is probably the foreign minister called Joseph Beck. Beck is a Calvinist very unusually for a poll. And he's a kind of great clever satin iron man, but everybody hates him. Well except for Goering I gather. Did Goering like him? Yeah he did because Beck had served in the German cavalry I think.
民主。所以在1926年，伟大的战时民族主义英雄毕苏斯基元帅发动了一场政变。然后他们建立了一个名为萨纳齐亚政权的独裁政权，意思是某种治愈政权。这是一种民族主义的独裁政权。这其中的关键人物可能就是外交部长约瑟夫·贝克。贝克是一位加尔文教徒，对于一个波兰人来说这很不寻常。他是一个既聪明又冷酷的铁人，但所有人都讨厌他。嗯，除了戈林，我收集到的信息是这样。戈林喜欢他吗？是的，他喜欢，因为贝克曾在德国骑兵服役，我想。
Right. During the war and was very pro-German. Like you he strongly disliked the French. Oh my word. Inevitably he disliked the Russians. Right. So Goering, Goering's a funny man isn't he? He's a strange man.
对的。在战争期间，而且非常亲德国。像你一样，他非常不喜欢法国人。天哪。不可避免地，他也不喜欢俄罗斯人。好吧。所以戈林，戈林是个有趣的人，对吧？他是个奇怪的人。
Yeah. Henderson, Beck and Goering they'd all had a great time going, shooting things. Yeah. Can I just ask, Czechoslovakia was a democracy. Yeah. And presumably that was part of, of why they were allies with Britain and France. Is it important that Poland isn't? Poland isn't.
是的。亨德森、贝克和戈林，他们都曾有过一段美好的时光，去打猎、射击之类的。是的。我能问一下，捷克斯洛伐克是一个民主国家。是的。据推测，这也是他们成为英国和法国盟友的原因之一，对吧？波兰不是民主国家，这很重要吗？波兰不是。
Yeah. Is that an issue? I don't think it's a massive issue deep down, because of course, there are lots of countries at this point that are not democracies. And I think it would have been an easier sell if it was, but actually the French, for example, the French are very Polonophile and have been for a very long time. Yeah, shopper. They regard themselves as having a kind of special relationship with Poland.
是的。这是一个问题吗？我不认为从根本上说这是一个巨大的问题，因为当然，此时有很多国家都不是民主国家。我想，如果它是的话，事情会更容易推销一些，但事实上，法国人，例如，法国人非常亲波兰，而且已经持续了很长时间。是的，购物狂。他们认为自己与波兰有一种特殊的联系。
And in Britain, do people say, oh, the Poles really, they're not a democracy? I don't think they do actually. I don't think they give it that much thought deep down. They don't really care what kind of government they have. The interesting thing is what Hitler and the Germans make of the polls. So most Germans hold the polls in very, very low regard. So in the 19th century, when a lot of Poland, of course, has been part of the Wilhelm Iron Reich, the Kaiser's regime, they had looked down on the polls. The Germans had said, well, the polls are very backward. The polls are very superstitious, they're very stupid. They actually had an
在英国，人们会说，哦，波兰人真的，他们不是一个民主国家吗？我认为他们实际上并没有这么说。我不认为他们从根本上对这个问题进行了那么多思考。他们并不真正关心波兰拥有什么样的政府。有趣的是希特勒和德国人对波兰人的看法。所以绝大多数德国人对波兰人的评价非常、非常低。因此，在19世纪，当波兰的大部分地区当然是威廉二世帝国（德意志第二帝国）、凯撒政权的一部分时，他们一直看不起波兰人。德国人曾说，嗯，波兰人非常落后。波兰人非常迷信，他们非常愚蠢。他们甚至有一个
expression, Polenwirtschaft, a Polish business, which meant kind of muddle and incompetence. They sort of looked on them. I suppose the analogy would be how people in the late 19th century in Britain talked about Ireland, as a kind of you know they can never govern themselves they're so disorganized and they're so backward and primitive and blah blah blah blah blah that's how Germans think of the Poles. Even in the 1920s lots of Germans said look in the long run Poland will have to cease to exist again there's no way we can live with a country called Poland on our eastern border. I mean the head of the army of the Weimar Republic, General Hans von Sicht in 1922 said, Poland's existence is intolerable and incompatible with Germany's
表达，Polenwirtschaft，意思是波兰式的经营，指的是混乱和无能。他们有点瞧不起他们。我想这个比喻就像19世纪末英国人谈论爱尔兰人的方式一样，某种你知道的，他们永远无法自己治理自己，他们是如此无组织，如此落后、原始，巴拉巴拉巴拉，德国人就是这样看待波兰人的。甚至在20世纪20年代，许多德国人也说，从长远来看，波兰将不得不再次停止存在，我们绝对无法与一个名为波兰的国家共存于我们的东部边界。我的意思是，魏玛共和国军队的司令汉斯·冯·塞克特将军在1922年曾说，波兰的存在是不可容忍的，与德国的
vital interests. It must and it will disappear through its own weakness and with our help through Russia. So even then the Germans are thinking that perhaps they should carve it up with the Russians. Yeah, because they have done before, like the partitions of the 1790s. But even though it's actually of course not Russia anymore, it's the Soviet Union. But they think, you know, it's kind of the law of nature and of history that the Poles never govern themselves. A bit like, you know, the Kurds don't have a state.
切身利益不相容。它必须而且将通过它自身的软弱，以及在俄罗斯的帮助下消失。所以即便在那个时候，德国人就已经在考虑也许他们应该和俄罗斯人瓜分它了。是的，因为他们以前这样做过，比如1790年代的瓜分。但尽管它实际上当然不再是俄罗斯，而是苏联。但他们认为，你知道，这是自然规律和历史规律，波兰人永远无法自己治理自己。有点像，你知道的，库尔德人没有国家一样。
They'll be one of those people who never get a state of their own. Okay. And so one guy who's very keen on this idea that the strong must prey on the weak is Hitler. What is his take on the Poles? Well, this is fascinating. Hitler, who of course later on is perceived as incredibly anti-Polish, he doesn't have a strong view about Poland at all before 1938.
他们将成为那些永远无法获得自己国家的民族之一。好的。因此，有一个非常热衷于强者必须捕食弱者这一观念的人，那就是希特勒。他对波兰的看法是什么？嗯，这很迷人。希特勒，当然在后来被认为是对波兰极其敌视，但在1938年之前，他对波兰根本没有什么强烈的看法。
He barely mentions Poland in Mein Kampf. And the obvious reason for this is that of course, Hitler is not German. I mean, Hitler is Austrian. Yeah, he's much further south, isn't he? So that's why he hates the Czechs. Yeah. So he never really thinks about the Poles. Why would he?
他在《我的奋斗》中几乎没有提到波兰。显而易见的原因是，当然，希特勒不是德国人。我的意思是，希特勒是奥地利人。是的，他在更南边，对吧？所以这就是为什么他讨厌捷克人。是的。所以他从不真正考虑波兰人。他为什么要考虑？
When he's in Vienna, the Galician Poles aren't massively playing on his mind. He doesn't care to think about Warsaw and all of that kind of stuff. And actually, in January 1934, he had overruled conservatives in the foreign office to sign a non-aggression treaty with Poland because he wanted to secure his Eastern flank. But people are always talking about these non-aggression pacts and things. Yeah, meaningless. They are meaningless, aren't they? That's totally meaningless.
当他在维也纳时，加利西亚的波兰人并没有大规模地占据他的心。他才懒得去想华沙以及所有诸如此类的事情。事实上，在1934年1月，他曾推翻了外交部保守派的意见，与波兰签署了一项互不侵犯条约，因为他想要确保他的东翼安全。但人们总是在谈论这些互不侵犯条约之类的事情。是的，毫无意义。它们毫无意义，不是吗？那完全毫无意义。
They're not worth the paper they're written on. No, unless you're Neville Chamberlain, in which case you love a piece of paper. But I think it's fair to say Adolf Hitler is not a man who adheres to a non-aggression pact. I think that's the one lesson we can all take from this, from these three seasons on the Nazis. But generally, I mean, do other powers stick by them? I mean, if the Soviet Union signs a non-aggression pact, for instance, I mean, were that to happen? Yeah.
它们连写下它们的纸张都不值。不，除非你是内维尔·张伯伦，那种情况下你对一张纸爱不释手。但我认为公平地说，阿道夫·希特勒并不是一个会恪守互不侵犯条约的人。我认为这是我们大家都可以从纳粹的这三季节目中吸取的唯一教训。但总的来说，其他大国会信守这些条约吗？我的意思是，如果苏联签署了一项互不侵犯条约，例如，如果这种情况发生的话？是的。
Do they think, yeah, we should stick with this or is that kind of bourgeois legalism? I think it depends on the country, doesn't it? I think if I signed a non-aggression pact with Stalin, I wouldn't necessarily have a great deal of confidence in his word. If I signed a non-aggression pact with Neville Chamberlain or de Ladié, then you would. I would. Wouldn't you? Yes, I would.
他们会想，是的，我们应该遵守这个，还是说这只是一种资产阶级法治主义？我认为这取决于国家，不是吗？我想，如果我和斯大林签署了一项互不侵犯条约，我未必会对他的承诺抱有很大的信心。如果我和内维尔·张伯伦或达拉第签署了一项互不侵犯条约，那么你就会有。我会的。难道你不会吗？是的，我会的。
But I mean, all these non-aggression pacts that everyone is fearlessly signing with Germany and the Soviet Union, I mean, it just seems a waste of effort. They've wasted their time, Tom. I think it's fair to say. Good. I'm glad I just seems a waste of effort. They've wasted their time, Tom. I think it's fair to say. Good. I'm glad I've got that sorted. So what does Hitler want to do with Poland? He's absolutely, even at the beginning of 1939, I'm not sure he's thinking about attacking and conquering it. He's thinking that Poland
但我的意思是，所有这些每个人都在无所畏惧地与德国和苏联签署的互不侵犯条约，我的意思是，这简直是在浪费精力。汤姆，他们是在浪费时间。我认为可以这么说。很好。我很高兴我刚刚——这简直是在浪费精力。汤姆，他们是在浪费时间。我认为可以这么说。很好。我很高兴我把这弄明白了。那么希特勒想对波兰做什么？他绝对，甚至在1939年初，我也不确定他是否在考虑攻击和征服它。他认为波兰
will just be a satellite, basically turn it into a client state, which is what he does with Slovakia and what he does with Hungary. Bind Poland to him as a loyal ally in the crusade against Bolshevism. And actually, you can see why he thinks he could do that. They have an authoritarian nationalist regime. The Poles had rather let themselves down at Munich. Yeah, so Hitler's given them a chunk of Czechoslovakia. He has. The old Silesian Duchy of Tetschen. Not the Silesian Duchy of Tetschen. Yeah. The Czechs and the Poles had fought each other for this in 1919 and the Czechs had got it and then the Poles snatch it back at the end of 1938.
将只成为一个卫星国，基本上把它变成一个附属国，这就是他对斯洛伐克和匈牙利所做的事情。将波兰绑架在他身边，作为反对布尔什维克主义十字军东征的忠实盟友。事实上，你可以看出为什么他认为他可以做到这一点。他们拥有一个独裁的民族主义政权。波兰人在慕尼黑问题上有点让自己失望了。是的，所以希特勒给了他们一块捷克斯洛伐克的领土。他确实给了。旧的西里西亚捷申公国。不是西里西亚的捷申公国。是的。捷克人和波兰人在1919年为这个地方打过仗，捷克人得到了它，然后波兰人在1938年底把它强行夺了回去。
This actually makes them all pretty pro-German, doesn't it? And they all kind of rush around Warsaw shouting out Long Live Hitler. Right. And actually there's a very famous moment. So two days after Munich, they got it and the Poles went in and the Czech general who handed it over to them, he said to the Polish general, well, you better make the most of this because I'll tell you what, you're going to be next. And the Poles are, ha ha ha, that will never happen. And how wrong they were. Anyway, three weeks after that moment, Ribbentrop asks the Polish ambassador, a man called Mr.
这实际上让波兰人变得相当亲德，不是吗？他们都跑到华沙街头高呼万岁希特勒。是的。事实上，有一个非常著名的时刻。所以在慕尼黑事件两天后，他们得到了它，波兰人进驻了，把土地移交给他们的捷克将军对波兰将军说，嗯，你最好好好利用这个，因为我告诉你，你们将是下一个。而波兰人则，哈哈哈，那永远不会发生。他们错得多么离谱。无论如何，在那一刻的三周后，里宾特洛甫要求波兰大使，一个名叫
Lipski, to come and see him. He says, we actually have a bit of a problem that we need to discuss. You can imagine the blood draining from the Polish ambassador's face. So here is the problem. After the First World War, when Poland had been carved out of these empires, the peacemakers of Versailles realized that Poland wasn't going to get any access to the sea at all, because it was on the northern flank of Poland. It was all East Prussia, which is German, and Lithuania. And they realized that they needed to give Poland an outlet to the sea. Otherwise, Germany in particular would have a complete stranglehold over Poland's trade,
利普斯基先生的人来见他。他说，我们其实有一个小问题需要讨论。你可以想象波兰大使脸上的血色瞬间褪尽。所以问题是这样的。第一次世界大战后，当波兰从这些帝国中被分割出来时，凡尔赛的和平缔造者们意识到波兰将根本无法获得出海口，因为波兰的北翼全是普鲁士东部（即德国领土）和立陶宛。他们意识到他们需要给波兰一个出海口。否则，特别是德国将对波兰的贸易、
its exports and imports. So they'd carved out this Polish corridor, as they called it, which is quite narrow. At the narrowest point, it's about 20 miles across. It went through West Prussia. So basically dividing Germany into two parts, into the main bit of the Reich and then East Prussia and then the Polish corridor between them. And that's not the kind of thing that Hitler would approve of, is it? Not at all, because the population of the Polish corridor is mixed.
出口和进口拥有完全的扼杀权。因此，他们划出了这个所谓的波兰走廊，它非常狭窄。在最窄的地方，大约有20英里宽。它穿过了西普鲁士。所以基本上把德国分成两部分，即帝国的本土部分和东普鲁士，以及它们之间的波兰走廊。这不是希特勒会批准的事情，对吧？一点也不，因为波兰走廊的人口是混合的。
It is majority Polish probably. I mean, this is very contested at the time by kind of rival census takers, but there's a very sizable German minority. And at the north end of this corridor on the coast is the city of Danzig or Dansk as it is today. And there was no doubt what kind of city Danzig is. It is a Hanseatic League German city. It looks kind of German. Now it had belonged to Poland. It had belonged to the Teutonic Knights. It had belonged to Poland again, and then it had belonged to Prussia.
它可能主要是波兰人。我的意思是，当时这受到各方竞争性人口普查数据的高度争议，但有一个非常可观的德国少数群体。在这个走廊北端的海岸上是但泽市（即今天的格但斯克）。毫无疑问但泽是什么类型的城市。它是一座汉萨同盟的德国城市。它看起来有点像德国城市。现在它曾属于波兰。它曾属于条顿骑士团。它曾再次属于波兰，然后它曾属于普鲁士。
The population of Danzig is definitely majority German speaking, at least 90%. I mean, you can go to Gdańsk today, which I have, it's the most amazing city to visit. It's incredibly rich architecturally and in history and whatnot. And it looks like a Hanseatic League city. However, Poland needs its outlet on the sea. So what the Versailles peacemakers did was they made Danzig a free city, an independent city state under the supervision of the League of Nations. So very Hanseatic. Yeah, very Hanseatic. It was governed by a Senate of basically German Senate, but the Poles had the
但泽的人口绝对是以德语为主的，至少有90%。我的意思是，你可以去今天的格但斯克，我去过，那是一个参观起来最奇妙的城市。它在建筑和历史等方面极其丰富。它看起来像一座汉萨同盟城市。然而，波兰需要它的出海口。所以凡尔赛的和平缔造者们所做的是，他们把但泽变成了一个自由市，一个在国际联盟监督下的独立城市国家。所以非常汉萨同盟。是的，非常汉萨同盟。它由一个基本上是德国参议院的参议院管辖，但波兰人拥有
right to use the harbor and they were given a post office there and customs posts and on this sort of peninsula across the harbor called the Westerplatte, which we'll be talking about a fair bit in the next couple of episodes, there was a Polish military garrison. And this was a massive running saw. This was a massive affront to German nationalist conservatives, especially if you're Prussian or something. Because Danzig is a place in important role in Prussian hearts. Yeah, absolutely. You're like, this is a Prussian city.
使用港口的权利，并且在那里被赋予了一个邮局和海关哨所，在这个横跨港口的名为韦斯特普拉特（Westplatte）的半岛上——我们将在接下来的几集里经常讨论这个地方——有一个波兰的军事驻军。这是一个长期未决的疮疤。这对德国民族主义保守派来说是一个巨大的侮辱，尤其是如果你是普鲁士人或诸如此类的人的话。因为但泽是一个在普鲁士人心目中占有重要地位的地方。是的，绝对的。你会觉得，这是一座普鲁士城市。
These people are Germans. It's not right that it's a free state. You know, it should really be part of the Reich and who cares about the Poles. That's basically the German position. So this is what Ribbentrop says to this ambassador. He says, right, we've had enough. We want Danzig back. Ribbentrop says to this ambassador, he says, right, we've had enough.
这些人是德国人。它是一个自由州是不对的。你知道，它真的应该是帝国的一部分，谁在乎波兰人。这基本上就是德国人的立场。所以这就是里宾特洛甫对这位大使所说的话。他说，好了，我们受够了。我们要回但泽。里宾特洛甫对这位大使说，他说，好了，我们受够了。
We want Danzig back. We also want to be able to build a motorway and a railway across the Polish corridor, which we control. We'll extend the non-aggression pact for another 25 years. Tom, I know your views on non-aggression pacts. That's a good deal. And we'd like you to join the anti-comment and pack to basically bind you into our alliance, our anti-Bolshevik alliance. The Polish guy says, all right, well, I'll take this back to Warsaw, see what they say. And the Poles reply very quickly and they say, absolutely no way.
我们要回但泽。我们还希望能够在我们控制的波兰走廊修建一条高速公路和一条铁路。我们将把互不侵犯条约延长25年。汤姆，我知道你对互不侵犯条约的看法。这是一笔好交易。我们希望你加入反共产国际协定，基本上把你们绑进我们的联盟、我们的反布尔什维克联盟中。波兰人说，好吧，我把这个带回华沙，看看他们怎么说。波兰人很快回复了，他们说，绝对没门。
We can't allow ourselves to be cut off from the sea. They couldn't have built a road under the German motorway and railway. What they could have undermined it with a road of their own. I mean, you'd have bridges, you could have a Polish motorway over the... It's not, to be fair, it's not motorway architecture that is the point of issue. I'm just trying to think creatively. I'm just trying to think of ways that the Second World War could have been stopped. Of course you are.
我们绝不能允许自己被切断与大海的联系。他们难道不能在德国的高速公路和铁路下面修建一条道路吗？他们可以用他们自己的道路在下面进行暗道挖通吗？我的意思是，你可以修桥，你可以在波兰的高速公路上方……说实话，这不是高速公路建筑学的问题所在。我只是试图进行创造性的思考。我只是在想阻止第二次世界大战爆发的方法。你当然是。
Neville Chamberlain joins us now on the bupust. Just trying to think creatively. We're going to hear from Lord Halifax now. Brilliant. Well, because let's face it, the consequences of the Poles deciding that they're going to resist German aggression for Poland and for millions and millions of Poles and especially Jewish Poles, I mean, is literally genocidal. Correct.
内维尔·张伯伦现在加入了我们的播客。只是试图进行创造性的思考。我们接下来将听到哈利法克斯勋爵的发言。太棒了。好吧，因为让我们面对现实吧，波兰人决定抵抗德国侵略的后果，对于波兰以及成千上万的波兰人、尤其是犹太裔波兰人来说，字面意思就是种族灭绝。正确。
They are. But I'm just wondering whether there was any possibility of a kind of modus operandi that could have been struck. No. And the reason is because if they do this, they turn themselves completely into a satellite of Germany, which they are never ever, ever going to do. Right. Okay.
他们确实是。但我只是在想，是否存在某种可能达成的行动方式或权宜之计。没有。原因在于，如果他们这样做，他们就会彻底把自己变成德国的卫星国，而这是他们绝对、绝对、绝对不会做的。好吧。
They think if we give them Tansi, we totally lose control of our trade. Germany will now control everything we export and everything we import because it has to go through this port pretty much. Or if it's going to go by land, it's got to go through Germany. So we just turn ourselves completely into a puppet. If we join the anti-committern pact, we are on Germany's side against Russia. Again, we lose control of our foreign policy. Yeah.
他们认为如果我们把但泽交给他们，我们就完全失去了对贸易的控制权。德国现在将控制我们出口和进口的一切，因为它基本上必须通过这个港口。或者如果要走陆路，就必须穿过德国。所以我们只是彻底把自己变成了一个傀儡。如果我们加入反共产国际协定，我们就站在了德国一边反对俄罗斯。同样，我们失去了对外政策的控制权。是的。
And they're bordering Russia. We're not going to do that. The point is Polish independence, which they fought for, which their forefathers have fought for for decades, for more than a century, they're not going to give that away, you know, like that. Now, Hitler at first thinks, oh, the Poles, they're being very difficult, but he doesn't immediately think I'm going to attack them. He thinks they will cease sense eventually.
而且他们与俄罗斯接壤。我们不会那样做的。关键在于波兰的独立，这是他们为之战斗过的，他们的祖先为了之战斗了数十年、一个多世纪的成果，他们是不会就这样轻易放弃的，你知道的。现在，希特勒起初认为，哦，波兰人，他们非常难缠，但他并没有立即想要攻击他们的想法。他认为他们最终会恢复理智。
He invites Beck to the eagle's nest. Beck goes along to the eagle's nest where Chamberlain went, and Beck says, look, you know, I can't help you. Polish public opinion will not allow us to give you these concessions. At this point, Hitler hasn't yet entered Prague. So he says to his aides, well, when I crush Czechoslovakia and I enter Prague, that will frighten the Poles and they will be more cooperative. So let's see if it does. Let's go forward in time to March. Six days after Hitler has entered
他邀请贝克去鹰巢。贝克去了张伯伦去过的鹰巢，贝克说，看，你知道的，我帮不了你。波兰的舆论不会允许我们做出这些让步。此时，希特勒尚未进入布拉格。所以他对他的助手们说，嗯，当我粉碎捷克斯洛伐克并进入布拉格时，那会吓倒波兰人，他们会变得更合作。所以让我们看看是不是这样。让我们把时间快进到三月。在希特勒作为征服者进入布拉格的六天后，
Prague as a conqueror, Ribbentrop again meets the Polish ambassador and he says, right, I need Beck to come to Berlin. We're running out of patience. Our newspapers have had enough. They're really putting pressure on us. If you give us Danzig, maybe we'll give you a little bit of Slovakia. We'll get a bit of Ukraine for you or something. Tell Beck to come anyway. We'll talk to him about it. And the ambassador five days later says, you know, Beck's not going to come. He doesn't want to come. You're not interested. He says he's not interested in anything that you could possibly offer him. And if you attack us, we'll fight you. Now you may say, this is real point here, Tom. This is reckless. This is incredibly bold.
里宾特洛甫再次会见了波兰大使，他说，好了，我需要贝克来柏林。我们的耐心正在耗尽。我们的报纸已经受够了。他们真的在向我们施压。如果你把但泽给我们，也许我们会给你一点斯洛伐克。我们会为你争取一点乌克兰或者别的什么。无论如何告诉贝克来吧。我们会和他谈谈的。五天后，大使说，你知道，贝克不会来了。他不想来。你没有兴趣。他说他对你可能提供给他的任何东西都不感兴趣。如果你攻击我们，我们会跟你打。现在你可能会说，汤姆，这才是真正的关键所在。这是鲁莽的。这是极其大胆的。
Beck's argument and the polls argument is we saw what happened to Czechoslovakia. I'm aware that I am being inconsistent here because I've been encouraging the Czechs to resist. Yeah. But I suppose also at this point, the polls think that they're only facing a conflict on one of their borders. They are indeed. They don't think there's any possibility of say, an alliance
贝克的论点和波兰人的论点是，我们看到了捷克斯洛伐克遭遇了什么。我知道我在这里前后矛盾，因为我一直在鼓励捷克人抵抗。是的。但我想同时在这个时候，波兰人认为他们只面临着来自其中一个边界的冲突。他们确实如此。他们认为根本不存在诸如苏联之间结盟的可能性。
between the Soviet Union. They absolutely don't. The Poles think, look, we saw with the Czechs what happened when you appease Hitler. When you give in to him, he just nibbles more and more and more and eventually comes back for the lot. The only way to stand up to him is just to draw a red line and to say no and then maybe he'll back off. And Beck gives this amazing speech actually to the same which is the Polish Parliament. He says, Peace is a precious and desirable thing. Our generation blooded in war certainly deserves peace. But peace like almost all things of this world has its price, a high but a measurable one. We in Poland do not know the concept of peace at any price. There
绝对没有。波兰人认为，看，我们在捷克人身上看到了当你绥靖希特勒时会发生什么。当你向他屈服时，他只会一点一点地蚕食，最后回来夺走全部。抵抗他的唯一方法就是划定一条红线并说不，然后也许他会退缩。贝克在瑟姆（即波兰议会）发表了这篇精彩的演讲。他说：“和平是一件珍贵而令人向往的事情。我们在战争中饱经血火洗礼的一代人当然配得上和平。但和平像这个世界上的几乎所有事物一样都是有代价的，这个代价高昂但可以衡量。我们波兰人不明白任何价格的和平的概念。在人类、民族和国家的生命中，只有一件东西是没有价格的，那就是荣誉。”
is only one thing in the lives of men, nations and countries that is without price and that thing is honour. And that's the attitude that a Prussian nobleman should respect and it reflects poorly on Prussian nobleman they don't respect in this case. Now Beck is confident that he can back this up because he has sent feelers out to London saying, will you back me up here? Please will you support me? Now we heard before the break, Chamberlain has already changed his policy and he thinks we need to deter Hitler. And his military chiefs are quite keen on an alliance with Poland because of course what they want is if there's a war with Hitler, they want Hitler to be fighting on two fronts, west
这就是普鲁士贵族应该尊重的态度，但这在某种程度上反映出普鲁士贵族并不尊重它，在这种情况下。现在贝克相信他能够支持这一点，因为他已经向伦敦发出试探，询问：“你们会在这里支持我吗？请你们支持我好吗？”现在我们在中场休息前听到，张伯伦已经改变了他的政策，他认为我们需要威吓希特勒。他的军事长官非常热衷于与波兰结盟，因为他们当然希望的是，如果与希特勒发生战争，他们希望希特勒在西线和东线两线作战。但是当然，英国武装援助到达波兰并没有真正的实际可能性。
and east. But of course, there's no real practical possibility of British armed aid reaching Poland. No, and we will come to this in the next couple of episodes that unfortunately, there is a difference of opinion between London and Warsaw about whether or not Britain can actually help Poland. As we shall shall see Britain doesn't. Now the French are also keen on alliance with Poland. They've got a long history of a friendship and de Ladier says to London, yeah we'll fight for Danzig. You know that's our red line, that's fine. That's the context for Chamberlain going to the House of Commons on the 31st of March 1939 and delivering his famous guarantee that if Polish independence is threatened and if Poland resists,
没有，我们将在接下来的几集里讨论这个问题，不幸的是，伦敦和华沙之间对于英国是否真的能帮助波兰存在着分歧。正如我们将要看到的，英国并没有这样做。现在法国也很热衷于与波兰结盟。他们有着悠久的友谊历史，达拉第对伦敦说，是的，我们会为但泽而战。你知道那是我们的红线，这很好。这就是3月31日张伯伦前往下议院发表他著名的保证的背景，即如果波兰独立受到威胁并且波兰抵抗，国王陛下的政府将感到自己有义务立即向波兰政府提供他们能力范围内的所有支持。
his majesty's government would feel themselves bound at once to lend the Polish government all support in their power. Now you made this point just a second ago. What does that actually mean? Like what could the British actually do? Britain is a long way from Poland and Germany is in the way. So realistically, what can we do? And actually even at this point, Chamberlain's military chief say to him, if Hitler does attack Poland, we're probably not going to do anything. There's nothing much we can practically do to help the Poles. But I suppose what Chamberlain would say in his defense is he doesn't see this as a last step, but as a first step. So he is thinking we'll get Poland, then we'll maybe get Romania in an alliance and ideally
你刚才提出了这一点。这到底意味着什么？英国人实际上能做什么？英国距离波兰很远，而德国挡在中间。所以现实地讲，我们能做些什么？实际上甚至在这个时候，张伯伦的军事长官也对他说，如果希特勒真的攻击波兰，我们可能什么也做不了。我们在实践中没有什么可以做来帮助波兰人的。但我想张伯伦为自己辩护时会说，他不认为这是最后一步，而是第一步。所以他在想，我们会争取到波兰，然后我们可能会让罗马尼亚加入联盟，理想情况下
maybe the Soviet Union. Well because that was the card that he could potentially have played over the Czech crisis. Yeah. But doesn't. I mean, that's the one card I'm guessing that Hitler would have. Yes, agreed. Of course, that's a very difficult card for any British government, especially a conservative government to play. They regard the Soviet Union really as the ideological arch enemy and have done
也许还有苏联。因为那是他在捷克危机中潜在可以打出的牌。是的。但没有打。我的意思是，那是我想象中希特勒唯一会拥有的牌。是的，同意。当然，对于任何英国政府来说，特别是保守党政府来说，这是一张非常难打的牌。他们一直将苏联视为意识形态上的死敌，并且已经持续了20年，你知道的，布尔什维克，斯大林的政权，一个血腥的政权，大清洗的传言和报告不断传出，乌克兰大饥荒和乌克兰大饥荒的传言。你知道，与苏联达成协议有巨大的障碍。
for 20 years, you know, the Bolshevik, Stalin's regime, a blood soaked regime, rumors, reports of the great terror coming out of, there's been rumors of the famine in Ukraine and the Holodomor. You know, there are big obstacles to a deal with the Soviet Union. And one of the biggest, by the way, is the Poles. The Poles, when they hear talk of this, they're like, what? The Russians. We hate the Russians. No way are we doing an alliance with the Russians.
而其中最大的障碍之一，顺便说一句，就是波兰人。波兰人当他们听到这种说法时，他们会想，什么？俄罗斯人。我们讨厌俄罗斯人。我们绝不与俄罗斯人结盟。
Are the British and the French, are they sufficiently alert to the fact that the Soviet Union is the great object of Nazi hatred? Yeah, they know that. They know that Hitler has rancid and raved about the Soviet Union for more than a decade. So the Soviet Union is quite keen on the idea of the capitalist powers fighting themselves, say Britain, France and Germany. I mean, is there any enthusiasm in Paris and London for the notion that the Nazis and the Soviets fight each other and we just sit back and watch them? Yes, absolutely. Somebody at Naval Chamberlain would have said to you, that's the dream.
英国人和法国人，他们是否充分警觉到苏联是纳粹仇恨的巨大对象这一事实？是的，他们知道。他们知道希特勒对苏联的愤怒和叫嚣已经持续了十多年。因此，苏联对资本主义大国互相残杀（比如英国、法国和德国）的想法非常感兴趣。我的意思是，在巴黎和伦敦，对于纳粹和苏联互相战斗而我们只是坐下来观看的观念，是否有任何热情？是的，绝对有。内维尔·张伯伦身边的人会告诉你，那是梦想。
Basically, they'll destroy each other. They're both terrible regimes and I hope they fight and they both lose. That's exactly what a lot of people in Britain and indeed in France would have said, I should say. Right. Okay. Does the Polish alliance complicate that? Because obviously Poland lies between Germany and the Soviet Union. So if they're allying with Poland, that complicates that strategy.
基本上，他们会互相摧毁。他们都是可怕的政权，我希望他们打起来，而且他们俩都输掉。这正是英国乃至法国许多人会说的话，我应该这么说。好吧。波兰同盟会让事情变得复杂吗？因为显然波兰位于德国和苏联之间。所以如果他们与波兰结盟，这就使该战略复杂化了。
So I think at this point in the March 1939, when they give the guarantee, they realize, of course, the next war is not going to be Hitler versus Stalin. The war that they're trying to avert is Hitler versus Poland. So Hitler versus Stalin is off the table as a war, realistically at that point. I just wonder whether they will game it and think if Hitler marches into Poland and seizes Poland, that is then a threat directly on the Soviet Union's doorstep. I mean, that's got to provoke a response, hasn't it? Wouldn't it be better to just sit back and let these two monstrous regimes fight each
所以我想在1939年3月这个时刻，当他们提供保证时，他们意识到，当然，下一场战争不会是希特勒对阵斯大林。他们试图避免的战争是希特勒对阵波兰。因此，从现实角度来看，希特勒对阵斯大林在那个时刻已经不在讨论范围内了。我只是在想，他们是否会进行博弈，认为如果希特勒进军波兰并占领波兰，那将是对苏联家门口的直接威胁。我的意思是，这一定会引发回应，不是吗？坐下来让这两个庞大的政权互相残杀，难道不是更好吗？
other? No, I don't think they think sitting back is an option at this point, because they think they've sat back too much already. There's no appetite for sitting back at option at this point, because they think they've sat back too much already. There's no appetite for sitting back at all at this point. All the momentum, all the kind of psychological, political momentum is for deterrence. They feel they have to make a stand here and they can't just sit this one out. That's the mentality that got them into this mess in the first place would be the argument. Do you think there's maybe an argument that this actually would have been a good time to apply that strategy in a kind of
不，我不认为他们认为坐下来是一个选项在这个时刻，因为他们认为他们已经坐下来太多了。此时根本没有任何坐视不管的胃口。所有的势头，所有那种心理上的、政治上的势头都在于遏制。他们觉得他们必须在这里表明立场，他们不能只是袖手旁观。这种心态正是让他们陷入最初困境的原因，这会是他们的论点。你认为可能有一种论点认为，这其实是一个以一种暗淡的冷嘲热讽运用这一战略的好时机吗？
bleak cynicism? Do you know who would probably make that argument? John Charmley, the historian John Charmley. Are you familiar with him? What's his name? The realist guy over Ukraine? Miersheimer. John Miersheimer. He might make this argument, but I wouldn't make it personally. I think they were right to try to deter Hitler in the States.
你知道谁可能会提出这个论点吗？约翰·查姆利，历史学家约翰·查姆利。你熟悉他吗？他叫什么名字？那个关于乌克兰的现实主义家伙？米尔斯海默。约翰·米尔斯海默。他可能会提出这个论点，但我个人不会这么做。我认为他们在当时试图威吓希特勒是正确的。
Well, it's not about right. It's about what's kind of cynically the most effective. Yeah. You know, who's a big fan of Miersheimer, the realist butanophile? Theo. Oh, of course he is. He is a massive fan of John Miersheimer. It's one of Theo's worst takes, I think, in my mind. Anyway, that's by the bite.
嗯，这不是对错的问题。这是关于从冷嘲热讽的角度来看什么是最有效的问题。是的。你知道谁是米尔斯海默的超级粉丝，那个现实主义的亲布者吗？西奥。哦，他当然是。他是约翰·米尔斯海默的超级粉丝。我认为这是西奥最糟糕的观点之一。无论如何，这题外话了。
Right. Hitler hears about the guarantee to... Don't cut that out, Theo. You're better than that. Hitler hears about the guarantee to Poland and he is stunned. See, this is Hitler misreading things, which he's doing at this point. Hitler can't believe it. He can't believe that the Poles would stand up to him and he cannot believe that the British would be so in his mind deranged as to give Poland a guarantee.
好吧。希特勒听到了对……的保证。别把那段剪掉，西奥。你比那更好。希特勒听到了对波兰的保证，他惊呆了。看，这就是希特勒误读事物的地方，他此时正在这么做。希特勒简直不敢相信。他不敢相信波兰人会挺身而出反抗他，他更不敢相信英国人会如此——在他看来——精神错乱，竟然给波兰提供保证。
And Admiral Canaris, the intelligence chief, was with him at the right chance when he heard the news and he has this description of Hitler. Hitler flew into a passion. With features distorted by fury, he stormed up and down his room, pounded his fists on the marble tabletop and spewed forth a series of savage imprecations. Then with his eyes flashing with an uncanny light, he growled the threat, I will brew them a devil's potion. I've always been struck by that because it just seems such a bizarre threat to make. I will brew
海军上将卡纳里斯，情报长官，当时在国家总理府和他在一起，当他听到这个消息时，他对希特勒有这样的描述。希特勒勃然大怒。随着因狂怒而扭曲的面容，他在房间里怒气冲冲地走来走去，用拳头捶打大理石桌面，并喷涌出一连串野蛮的诅咒。然后，他的眼睛闪烁着诡异的光芒，他低声发出威胁：“我要为他们酿造一杯魔鬼的药剂。”我一直对这句话印象深刻，因为它看起来是一个如此离奇的威胁。我要酿造
them a death... must be some German expression. No? Do you think, Tom? I guess. I mean, it's not an expression that people are banding around in the 1930s. I hate us spending too much time in Wagner. That's what it is, isn't it? Yeah, maybe. I mean, if the devil is embodiment of evil, he does body bruise for Poland. I mean, is the essence of evil. It is, but you wouldn't say that of yourself, would you? I don't know. I mean, I find it striking that he talks in, I know it's just a phrase, but kind of implicit theological terms, because in the long run, what happens in Nazi occupied Poland will raise all kinds of questions about evil and the absence of good. Absolutely it does. So inevitably now he tells his generals to draw up their plans for war
“给他们一个死亡……”这一定是个德语表达。不是吗？汤姆，你觉得呢？我想是吧。我的意思是，这不是那种在20世纪30年代人们到处乱用的表达。我讨厌我们在瓦格纳身上花太多时间。就是这样，对吧？是的，也许吧。我的意思是，如果魔鬼是邪恶的化身，他确实在为波兰大打出手。我的意思是，这是邪恶的本质。是的，但你不会那样评价你自己，对吧？我不知道。我的意思是，我感到震惊的是，他谈论时使用的是——我知道这只是一种短语——某种隐含的神学词汇，因为从长远来看，纳粹占领的波兰所发生的事情将引发关于邪恶和善之缺失的各种问题。确实如此。因此，他现在不可避免地命令他的将军们制定战争计划
and they present him on the 11th of April with a plan for Fallweiss case or operation white. So they're all colors aren't they? They're all colors, yeah. Green, white and so on. The blueprint for the invasion of Poland, which is their plan is to begin in September and the army chief of staff, General Halder, he briefs the senior officers, he say we're going to destroy the Polish army at record speed. We're going to stop the British intervening.
并在4月11日向他提交了一份关于“白色方案”（Fall Weiss）或“白色行动”的计划。所以它们都是以颜色命名的，对吧？是的，都是以颜色命名。绿色、白色等等。入侵波兰的蓝图规定他们的计划于9月份开始，陆军参谋长哈尔德（Halder）将军向高级军官们做了简报，他说我们将以创纪录的速度消灭波兰军队。我们将阻止英国人进行干涉。
He says, the Poles are no serious opponents. We know we can defeat the Poles, but even at this point, Halder says to the other officers, this is not going to be an ordinary war. We are going to take the SS and we are going to take Nazi paramilitary formations with us. We must ensure that, and I quote, Poland as rapidly as possible is not only defeated but liquidated. And do we have a sense of what that means? Well, we'll come to this in the next couple of episodes exactly what that means. At this
他说，波兰人不是什么可怕的对手。我们知道我们可以击败波兰人，但即使在这个时候，哈尔德对其他军官说，这不会是一场普通的战争。我们将带上党卫军，我们将带上纳粹准军事组织。我们必须确保，我引用一下，“波兰以尽可能快的速度不仅被击败，而且被清算”。我们对这意味着什么有什么概念吗？嗯，我们将在接下来的几集里详细讨论这到底意味着什么。在这个
point it is vague. So he might be talking about the state. Yes. But he might, I mean, be talking about people. Yes, exactly. Exactly. We're going to do it in three weeks, Helder says, and then we will be ready either to confront Bolshevism or to hurl our army against the West. So at this point, there is still a question mark there. After we've finished with Poland, do we go West or do we go East? And now we had a few twists last week.
时候，它是模糊的。所以他可能是在谈论国家。是的。但我的意思是，他可能是在谈论人。是的，没错。没错。哈尔德说，我们将在三周内完成这一切，然后我们就准备好要么对抗布尔什维克主义，要么将我们的军队投向西方。所以在这一点上，仍然存在一个问号。在我们解决完波兰之后，我们是向西走还是向东走？现在我们在上周经历了一些转折。
Here is the biggest, one of the most momentous, ominous and extraordinary twists in world diplomatic history. Yeah. I mean, it's the greatest coup d'etat in the history of, of diplomacy, I would guess. It is. Because it's about this point, April, 1939, that some of Hitler's courtiers begin kind of quietly to discuss a U-turn that would change everything. And they mention it to Hitler. And when they first mention it to Hitler, he says, I don't know about this. That would be a massive ideological shift. I'm not sure about it. And then a couple of weeks later in early May, 1939, the story goes that Ribbentrop shows him footage of another world leader reviewing a military parade.
这里是最大、最具重大意义、最不祥且最非凡的世界外交史转折之一。是的。我的意思是，我猜这是外交史上最伟大的一次政变。确实是。因为正是在这个时候，即1939年4月，希特勒的一些近臣开始悄悄讨论一个将改变一切的急转弯。他们向希特勒提及此事。当他们第一次向希特勒提起时，他说，我不知道这行不行。那将是一个巨大的意识形态转变。我对此没有把握。然后几周后，即1939年5月上旬，据传里宾特洛甫给他看了一段另一个世界领导人检阅阅兵式的录像。
And Hitler watches this footage intently and he's staring at this bloke's face, like it said, like he had taken a fancy to him. And then at last he says, he looks like a man that you could do business with and that man is Stalin. Well Dominic, what a twist, what a bombshell. And we will be back on Thursday to see how the rapprochement between these two mustachioed dictators with a taste for killing people works out. But if you can't wait to hear about the Nazi Soviet pact, which will be the subject of
希特勒聚精会神地看着这段录像，他盯着这家伙的脸，就像他看上了他一样。最后他说，他看起来像是一个你可以和他做生意的人，而那个人就是斯大林。多米尼克，真是个转折，真是个重磅炸弹。我们将在周四回归，看看这两位爱好杀戮的胡子独家之间的关系缓和将如何发展。但是，如果你迫不及待地想听到关于《苏德互不侵犯条约》的内容，这将是我们的主题
our next episode and then our final episode, the countdown to the second world war and the tragic story of the fall of Poland, then you can hear all three episodes right now by joining the Rest is History club at therestishistory.com. Goodbye. Goodbye. Riegel Goodbye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
下一集，然后是我们的最后一集，关于第二次世界大战倒计时和波兰沦陷的悲惨故事，那么你可以通过在 therestishistory.com 加入“历史其余部分俱乐部”（The Rest is History Club），现在就收听所有三集节目。再见。再见。再见。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。